non pas du tout je crois que ce qui
résume le mieux c'est ce que vient de
dire un député de la république en
marche c'est un texte technique qui ne
s'attaque pas aux problèmes de fond on
est est une réserve qui clôt ah oui une
petite loi administrative sans autorité
sans vision sans fermeté sans moyens il
est là aussi le problème sans moyens
donc on aura comme on l'a souvent avec
les textes présentés par le gouvernement
macron un débat puis une absence totale
des faits qui accouchera la montagne a
accouché d'une souris
une absence totale des faits si on
souhaite contrôler les politiques
migratoires
si on souhaite empêcher davantage
d'immigration dans notre pays or je
pense que c'est pas la philosophie
vous êtes en voiture pour qualifier ce
projet ce n'est pas trop de farès
khachan les bonnes mesures dans ce texte
surnom c'est une imposture helmand parce
que ce gouvernement nous dit on va être
plus sévère alors on va faire attention
et que la réalité derrière il ne met pas
de moyens je vous donne un exemple le
nombre de places dans les centres de
rétention administrative
il y a deux cents places je crois de
plus prévues dans le texte
c'est ridicule par rapport au nombre de
personnes qui seraient en capacité ou
dans la nécessité d'aller dans des
centres dans ces centres de rétention
administrative
on est tellement loin de ce qu'il faudra
faire qu'en réalité le gouvernement avec
une petite cuillère à café trou et
essaye de combler la brèche de ce qu'il
faut bien le dire une submersion
migratoire qui s'abat sur notre pays et
ce texte est sous le feu de certaines
critiques notamment celles du défenseur
des droits qui estime que le demandeur
d'asile et mal traitée avec ce texte
comment vous réagissez à assat oui au
fait le défenseur des droits monsieur
toubon qu'on a connu plus plus ferme
d'ailleurs dans d'autres dans d'autres
moments de sa vie
il est payé pour faire ça et il est payé
pour prendre la défense des migrants
vial bourse de faire et bien moi ni té
de non non non moi je suis payé voyez
vous je suis élu est payé pour défendre
mes compatriotes et je pense que dans le
cas présent dans le cas d'espèce les
propositions du député aurélie attachés
et bien font état d'une préférence
migratoire quand vous donnez c'est dans
les propositions d'aurélien tâche et qui
seront intégrés au débat parlementaire
d'après ce que j'ai compris quand vous
donnez une impasse culture de 500 euros
à chaque demandeur d'asile quel français
consacre 500 euros par an à l'accès à la
culture
certainement pas des électeurs du nord
qui ont suffisamment de difficultés vous
voulez y ait une préférence migratoires
à travers ce texte et à travers les
recommandations qu'ils ont fait qui va
évidemment à l'encontre de ce qu'il
faudrait